this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
army's museum in the uk which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and
thanks to a few battlefield pvp practice
servers we're able to show jonathan the
cobbled together weapons of rust wow
what a monster so this is a 12k shotgun
i think this is meant to be made from
plumbing supplies
if there are any other games guns and
mechanics that you guys want to see
jonathan break down let us know in the
comment section below make sure to
subscribe for more videos like this one
and if you'd like to help out the royal
armies museum and continue to support
jonathan's work check out the links in
the description of this video right over
to jonathan
all right this is a really really quite
a fun one for me because this weapon if
i can call it a weapon is something
that's actually from the royal armouries
collection and i have it with me today
it's not identical to what we see on
screen as i'll explain in a moment but i
am about 90 odd percent sure that the
aoka pistol is based directly on this
specific object so the difference is the
big one i mean the stick's the same
pretty much and the wire wrapping it
onto the uh together the big difference
is the barrel which in the game is some
sort of an iron tube whereas on the real
thing it's a 20 millimeter cartridge
case and to make it a barrel all they've
done is
dent in the top of it and drill that in
the center to create not only a touch
hole or a vent if you prefer but a pan
for the priming powder and that's
probably the biggest divergence from the
game version this is really a medieval
handgun or hand cannon recreated using
the cartridge case as a barrel
and you need that depression to fill
with powder so that there's something to
go flash
so that the gun goes back what we see in
rust is the player is striking the
barrel with a rock and it's creating a
spark
off the iron or steel barrel and the
sparks somehow going into the gun
setting it off it's not completely
implausible but it's pretty daft so
whereas this is not not a very good
weapon and but it would fire for for one
shot the one in the game i'm not
confident would work at all they've kind
of covered that by showing it require
multiple random hits from the rock to
actually fire
so
they put that level of thought into it
there are there are some some fun and
interesting weapons in this game for
sure this is the shovel ak kind of
infamous in the firearms world because
around about 2008 photos of a an ak with
a shovel grip buttstock appeared on the
internet instantly the image sort of
spoke to that post-apocalyptic vibe of
how would you keep a gun like this in
functional order if you haven't got
spare parts but actually what it was was
even more fascinating guy i believe in
the states had decided to make a
kalashnikov rifle which is what we're
looking at here a caricature of version
of one to make an ak out of a shovel and
he didn't just use the grip the handle
as the buttstock he took the blade of
the shovel heated it hammered it and
forged it into the u-shaped main
receiver of the rifle so how's that
relevant to what we're seeing here well
of course you can't say necessarily that
this
receiver's been made out of a shoveled
blade but i wonder if they're trying to
hint at it because it is a solid
receiver with the top cover kind of
integral to it and those of you who know
the kalashnikov no that's not how it
works it also
diverges from the ak in the selector
switch which is a thumb selector switch
more like a gleal and if we look at the
other side we see that there's no there
isn't the classic
big ak safety selector switch lever
that's just not there different design
around the ejection port different
cocking handle so it's a sort of a
squint and it's an ak easily close
enough to be
a tribute to the famous shovel ak
[Applause]
i quite like this improvised bolt action
rifle it looks like it's something you
could actually build and might actually
work although the receiver is looks to
be welded sheet metal and you need it to
be quite strong up front where the
barrel is attached depending very much
what it actually shoots the way the
thing sh actually fires is kind of
curious um i'm not sure if other weapons
in the game are doing this too but the
recoil is slightly off so the gun is
built as a right-hander as it should be
and it's fired from the right shoulder
and yet it's recoiling off to the left
one-handed pistol shooting will do that
because of the sort of bio-mechanics of
how you're holding it and how it recoils
rifles though because they're nestled in
your shoulder and pushing you back and
to the right so that's a bit weird bit
counterintuitive
so the rifle we've got here i did have
to look this one up because it's
although it's clearly an ar-15
derivative it's not one that i was
familiar with and it is the lr300
so one of the sort of tactical flares
that we see in the handling of the lr300
is that they flip the gun onto its left
side and look at the right side the idea
of that is if you're not counting your
rounds that the idea there is the gun
stops firing you quickly flick it over
to check that it hasn't jammed and is in
fact empty the bolt is locked to the
rear there's no cartridge case in the
feed way or anything then you flip it
back over the way to reload it but
that's what that is okay so anyone was
wondering quite an interesting effect
visible there where we're shooting at
some distance and you can see the bullet
drop but what i'm seeing is the the
rounds are hitting the ground and
they're bouncing up which is a real
phenomenon smaller calibers like 556
which is what this would be probably not
so much not something i've witnessed
because they're very small they tend to
break up when they hit something for a
game that isn't trying too hard on the
realism front it's quite impressive that
they've got their ballistic models
worked out like that
this is of course the fn minime uh
specifically it's the m249 um it's quite
detailed in the modeling however when we
reload this importantly when there are
no rounds left there's still a complete
belt of ammunition in the gun somehow
they've stopped at a certain point in
modeling this thing effectively or at
least in the in the reload animation it
behaves quite believably kind of works
as you'd expect an lmg to work certainly
in a in a game
here we see it used to literally batter
down a wall um maybe 556 isn't the ideal
caliber to be total breaching at all
that makes sense so um and actually i
don't know how effective it would be i
think you'd have to use quite a lot of
ammunition especially 556 to blow enough
small holes in the door to actually
remove it which is what we see happening
here
so this is where it gets particularly
interesting with post-apocalyptic
setting and improvised firearms whereas
this thing is craft produced it's been
made by somebody i've grabbed a couple
of examples from from our collection to
illustrate the range that this can
encompass and this one is actually a
similar configuration to what we see on
screen it's about the same proportions
now this is actually a more of a small
factory made gun than
a man in a shed and so it's finished to
quite a high standard at the other end
of the homemade slash craft produced
spectrum is this thing
and this is more akin to what we see
in the game here this one is
a northern ireland loyalist terrorist
example sheet metal and that round
tubing and then the all-important solid
steel barrel and
bolt how well it works i can't say
not very would be my guess also a point
worth making about this is it has the
the classical video game grip wrap that
doesn't always make a lot of sense well
here may not be essential but it's quite
important it gets quite chilly up in up
in northern europe and so
cold and potentially sharp metal under
your hand is not ideal so they've just
put a lot of turns of black electrical
tape around this to give you something
of a comfortable
grip nice that they've gone they've got
quite a lot of trouble in conceiving
this they haven't copied as far as i
know any any specific homemade design
they've come up with their own based on
things they've seen and it looks quite
plausible
mp5
my
favorite modern
modern firearm i think don't necessarily
think it's
firing quickly enough it sort of chugs
along a little bit in this one and it
definitely looks looks decent loads as
it should now the mp5 and weapons like
that in this kind of collapse of
civilization setting are going to be a
bit more problematic to keep running
than a lot of other designs the the
roller delay
will wear out wills become less reliable
over time and eventually it won't work
and you probably wouldn't be able to
find the spare parts for it
headshot headshot headshot
yo he dead
so the other submachine gun proper
submachine gun in the game is the
thompson it's a good model it looks
suitably
distressed and most notably buttstock
has had a catastrophic failure at some
point and they have taped on some kind
of metal rod replacement for it i think
i'd probably just give up and use it
without rather than what looks like an
extremely wobbly arrangement there and
the front hand grip has also become
detached despite two very large looking
bolts on there and
is taped in place so it gives it that uh
that aesthetic whether the thompsons
would still be around and functioning i
don't know how many years in the future
this is meant to be but you'd probably
be able to get that keep that running
maybe um if you are the sort of person
who can
make a firearm from scratch or have
access to people who can make firearms
from scratch they could probably keep a
simple blowback submachine gun like this
in working order fabricate new parts for
it probably and not the typical setting
for a tommy gun we've had it crop up in
fallout of course but um yeah it's not
it's not your go-to mad max-esque weapon
i'm liking the look of the homemade
shotgun it's vaguely reminiscent
not in look but in function of the
wichita 1897 shocker pump action shotgun
where the bolt will protrude back over
your hand when you operate it just
because of the design of the receiver um
most modern shotguns all modern shotguns
contain the bolt within the receiver so
you don't have that sticking out you
have to worry about where your hand is
so you do on this one otherwise it's
quite a chunky looking sheet welded
sheet metal design that looks somewhat
plausible the magazine tube well first
of all it's visibly got a spring in
there so it's housing the pump grip more
than it is housing a magazine shoe by
the look of it so i don't know where all
six of those rounds are gonna go i don't
think they've sort of thought that one
through
i am less of a fan of the sort of pipe
guns this rifle has got a big open drawn
tube as a receiver which doesn't inspire
confidence if this thing's meant to be
as it appears to be 556 some kind of
rifle caliber homemade guns firing rifle
calibers are problematic because they
are operating at much higher chamber
pressure there's a reason why you
typically see pistol calibers shotgun
rounds that level of pressure because
you can more easily design a gun to take
that unlike some
homemade looking guns and games where
they don't really look like anything
this looks like it has been made from
stuff which i very much appreciate some
sort of bit of bit of driftwood as the
um as the stock there i don't know that
you would bother with an enveloping
stock like that especially as it doesn't
actually have a wooden butt stock as
part of it we've got separate a separate
tubular stock bolted to the wood but hey
homemade guns are at the whim of the
maker or designer so we can't be too
critical of that and we've got a wooden
bit of wood taped to the barrel as a
heat shield which you would need for
this
yeah so in terms of real real world
weapons this thing is a bit of a mess
it's a big heavy pipe this is this is
meant to be a launcher of an explosive
munition so a big heavy pipe would be a
good start and improvised launches like
this have been made so you can look this
up um the acronym was uh prig and it was
the um projector recoilless improvised
grenade and this was an
improvised ira shoulder-fired launcher
now the thing about that was
about any launcher of a big heavy bomb
or rocket munition
is that you need to balance the recoil
because if you're firing this thing or
launching this thing you've got to
account for physics every action having
an equal and opposite reaction if you
just have a closed tube a gun and you
fire essentially a
five pound bullet out of it whatever it
is you will be on your ass from the
recoil so one of which is to say this
thing is a shoulder fired gun it is not
a recoilless weapon it is not a rocket
launcher it wouldn't work won't work but
you would be you would fall over every
time you fired it
back to
quite a nice plausible looking homemade
ish revolver so
when this thing is opened up we see well
firstly that it's eight shots which is
unusual there is also very little real
estate in that cylinder to accommodate
all those chambers you need thick
chamber walls just like you need thick
barrel walls and if you look at that
open cylinder there's a little
wafer thin bit of metal between chambers
that would quite simply blow through uh
if not with the first shot then with
with successive shots the other thing
this reveals is there's no ratchet on
the back of the cylinder so there's no
actual means of rotating it so all
things considered what this should be is
a manually operated revolver and the
other side of it is how you're cocking
and firing the hammer or the striker
there's no visible means of that
happening as you pull the trigger there
isn't space in the frame really for that
kind of lock work so i would see this
plausibly only working if you manually
cocked it like the
striker on the liberator pistol from the
second world war
what a monster i mean if the jubilee if
the hose clips weren't a clue the
flanges on the pipes would be i think
this is meant to be made from plumbing
supplies so this is a 12-gauge shotgun
it breaks open like a 12k shotgun the
big issue here is there's no latch for
that big heavy barrel so just on a very
practical level it's not going to stay
shut but certainly when you fire it
there's going to be a lot of pressure on
on there trying to force it apart at the
pivot i'd be a bit concerned about that
and the other thing about this design is
we've got the the classic 12 gauge
shotgun extraction and ejection going on
but there's no actual way of that
happening you would be looking for a
handy rod to bang out what would
probably be a stuck cartridge case or
desperately trying to get your
fingernail in which wouldn't end well i
don't think
if you'd like to see more of the royal
armouries collection we have our own
youtube channel that you can head over
and check out we've also got links in
the description for
ways to
donate to us and also
links to my book which is this is on
bullpup british firearms but is also
available from the royal armouries shop
so if you're in the uk it will be
cheaper on the shipping in any case i'll
see you again next time thanks very much
[Music]
[Music]
you